si monsieur le président du sénat
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs si
juste si j'utilise aujourd'hui l'alinéa
4 de l'article 49 de la constitution
pour vous demander l'approbation de la
déclaration de politique générale c'est
pour exprimer mon respect du
bicaméralisme du bicamérisme qui fonde
nos institutions est ma grande
considération pour la chambre haute
cette procédure est rare dans l'histoire
de la vème république
j'ai choisi de l'utiliser par souci de
clarté de responsabilité dans un moment
de bascule de notre vie politique qui
nous invite à dépasser les clivages
anciens le 5 juillet 2017
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous présentais ma première déclaration
de politique générale
la plupart des engagements que j'y
prenais conformément au programme du
président de la république sont tenues
ou en cours d'accomplissement notre
conviction qu'il y a urgence à faire
avancer le pays n'a pas changé notre
détermination s'est même accru les
français se sont exprimés lors des
élections présidentielle et législatives
de 2010 est et plus récemment lors des
élections européennes
et je n'oublie pas que les grands
électeurs se sont pour leur part exprimé
en septembre 2017
mais nous savons tous que nos
concitoyens ne s'exprime pas seulement
les jours d'élection la démocratie ce
n'est pas seulement glissé son bulletin
dans une urne
quelles que soient nos affinités
partisanes quelles que soient les
sensibilités politiques que vous
incarnez et que vous représentez vous
avez pu mesurer comme nous tous ces
derniers mois
à quel point nos concitoyens sont
préoccupés et souvent en colère chez
beaucoup d'entre eux s'expriment un
violent rejet des injustices
territoriales et fiscales des
complexités administratives des ratés de
notre système de solidarité
un sentiment de colère face à la vie
chère une société bloquée à l'ascenseur
social qui ne fonctionne plus pour
beaucoup la politique est devenue
synonyme d'incompréhension et de
dépossession nos compatriotes demande
plus de proximité plus de participation
le président malhuret dans une
intervention remarquée l'a dit comme
d'habitude avec des termes précis et
sans complaisance
en même temps que leur incompréhension
et leur colère beaucoup expriment leur
aspiration à l'engagement pour leur
valeur pour leur ville pour leurs
enfants ou pour la planète vivre
dignement de son travail respirer un air
pur avoir accès à une alimentation de
qualité pouvoir se déplacer quand on
habite à la campagne pratiquer une
activité sportive ou culturelle
voilà qu'il ya dix ans pour nos
concitoyens créer des emplois et des
richesses tout en gardant la sagesse de
valoriser aussi et peut-être surtout ce
qui n'a pas de prix l'éducation le
patrimoine artistique la transmission
des valeurs
l'accompagnement des malades ou des
personnes âgées voilà ce qui préoccupe
aussi nos concitoyens voilà ce qui
réconcilie le politique la politique et
la proximité voilà ce qui peut nous
réconcilier durablement avec les
français nous qui nous sommes engagés
quels que soient les idées ou les
valeurs que nous portons pour améliorer
leur vie quotidienne
je ne vous révèlerai pas la déclaration
de politique générale que j'ai prononcé
hier à l'assemblée nationale vous l'avez
parfaitement entendu grâce au ministre
d'état françois de rugy
je mesure la surprise qui a été la vôtre
est sans doute la sienne lorsque vous
l'avez entendu vous dire qu'il venait de
la droite qu'il avait été salarié d'une
grande entreprise du nucléaire je le
remercie d'avoir porté ma voix devant
vous en sachant se prendre la distance
nécessaire entre celui qui écrivait
celui qui disait vous avez donc compris
que nous engagions l'acte 2 du
quinquennat du président de la
république cet acte ii s'inscrit dans la
continuité du premier acte mais s'en
distingue très fortement par la méthode
nous ne renie rien nous sommes fiers des
avancées qui ont été acquises depuis
deux ans pour libérer le travail tout en
renforçant les filets de sécurité qui
protège nos concitoyens les plus
vulnérables nous sommes fiers aussi
d'avoir consenti un effort sans
précédent en décembre en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens
c'était nécessaire pour redonner de la
confiance et de l'oxygène à beaucoup de
français
cet effort se poursuivre à répondre à
l'urgence écologique et le premier axe
de notre feuille de route j'ai présenté
hier mon plan de bataille pour les
prochains mois nous allons accélérer la
transformation environnemental de notre
économie et de nos transports rendre
plus accessible et plus incitative les
aides à la rénovation énergétique en
finir avec un consumérisme qui consiste
à jeter a gaspillé avec une insouciance
inconsidérés et qui met en danger la
qualité de notre alimentation et de la
biodiversité
certains nous reprocheront toujours de
ne pas aller assez vite ou assez loin
mais hier j'ai présenté nombre de
mesures qui transforme nos modes de
production de transport de consommation
de vie michel serres qui aimait nos
terroirs et qui aimait la mère qui fut
un grand penseur de l'écologie défendait
d'ailleurs une et d'une idéologie de la
courbe et non de la rupture
nous sommes convaincus nous aussi que
respecter la nature comprendre les
enjeux de notre époque c'est respecter
le temps des transformations sûr et
durable
plus que des soubresauts hâtif et
irréfléchie je ne crois pas à l'écologie
du grand soir je crois à l' écologie qui
agrège qui embarque qui change les actes
et pas nuque pas uniquement la une des
journaux
de surcroît réparer la planète en
habillement le lien social ne mène nulle
part
c'est pourquoi la seconde urgence qui
nous anime est de réduire les injustices
fiscales sociales et territoriales
la cartographie de ces injustices
coïncide d'ailleurs en partie car au
centre de la carte il ya le coeur
battant du pays la france de ce qu'on
appelle par commodité des classes
moyennes et sucker on entend qu'il
s'essouffle beaucoup de villes comme
cahors limoges des pierres sont hautains
membres'' où les abîmes reste des villes
à taille humaine dynamique mais sont
fragilisés par la déprise démographique
l'attraction des grandes métropoles et
le départ de certains services publics
notre programme action coeur de ville
contribuera bientôt à renouveler le
paysage urbain de 222 de ces villes dans
toutes nos régions
à angoulême l'ancienne clinique
sainte-marthe désaffectée depuis 1999
sera transformé en logements ainsi qu'un
îlot de cinq immeubles vacants et muret
à cahors la reconquête du centre-ville
se traduira notamment par la
construction d'un nouveau cinéma
l'accès à l'art au numérique ne doit pas
être un privilège parmi d'autres qui
fracturent est notre territoire
beaucoup de territoires ruraux se
battent s'équipant numérique valorisent
leurs atouts mais s'estiment délaissées
décroché dans la rapide transformation
du monde partout en france des femmes et
des hommes peinent à boucler leurs fins
de mois
dans leurs contributions sur la
plateforme du grand débat et qu'ils
étaient nombreux à dénoncer le coût de
la vie que nous lisons parfois comme un
coup avec un p qui nous met à terre pour
ces hommes et ces femmes
nous voulons que les impôts plaisent
moins que le travail paye mieux c'est
pour eux que nous baisserons l'impôt sur
le revenu de 5 milliards et que nous
supprimerons la totalité de la taxe
d'habitation pour les 12 millions de
foyers qui correspondent à la première
tranche de l'ir pp cela représente un
gain de 350 euros en moyenne pour les 5
millions de foyers de la tranche
suivante ce sera en moyenne 180 euros au
total les impôts des ménages laisseront
de près de 27 milliards d'euros durant
ce quinquennat
ces baisses seront votées dans le projet
de loi de finances et seront effectives
dès le 1er janvier 2020
vous mesurez autant que moi le coût de
ces mesures
rien n'est jamais gratuit rien je
transigeraient malaisément avec l'idée
de transmettre à mes enfants mes dettes
y compris celles qui viennent de mes
parents c'est pourquoi
l'annnonce de ces baisses d'impôts exige
une discipline il n'y a pas d'autre
solution pour financer les baisses
d'impôts que de trouver des économies et
de travailler plus nous avons en matière
de finances publiques
un bilan qui nous donne une légitimité
en 2017
au prix d'un effort remarqué et contesté
parfois dès notre arrivée nous avons
enfin ramener la défie le déficit sous
la barre des 3% en 2018
nous avons stabilisé la dette et je le
dis mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
pour la première fois depuis 40 ans les
dépenses publiques ont reculé en volume
ces chiffres certains considèrent qu'ils
sont insuffisants
mais je les renverrait à leur propre
bilan
les gouvernements auxquels ils ont
participé
où les majorités qui ont soutenu de tel
gouvernement ont elles aussi fortement
augmenté les dépenses publiques et je
les renverrait à leurs contradictions
car après avoir promis 500 mille
suppressions de fonctionnaires ou la
suppression de l'intégralité des emplois
aidés ils n'ont pas été les derniers à
critiquer les mesures courageuses que
nous avons prises en la matière en
parallèle de la nécessaire maîtrise des
dépenses publiques
il nous faut travailler davantage
revaloriser le travail implique de
rénover profondément notre système
d'assurance chômage
le plein emploi n'est ni une utopie ni
un néologisme allemand c'est un objectif
réaliste auquel on a trop longtemps
renoncé faute de vision et de courage
avec la ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud nous détaillerons la semaine
prochaine la manière dont nous voulons
réformer l'assurance chômage pour
inciter au retour à l'emploi durable
nous voulons responsabilité
responsabiliser les entreprises qui
abusent des contrats courts à travers un
mécanisme de bonus malus sur les cinq à
dix secteurs qui utilisent le plus dans
notre économie
ces contrats courts nous voulons
permettre aux démissionnaires et aux
travailleurs indépendants de se lancer
dans de nouveaux projets nous voulons
que le travail paye toujours mieux que
l'inactivité
nous assumons la dégressivité de
l'indemnisation pour les salariés dont
les revenus sont les plus élevés car ce
sont ceux qui retrouvent le plus
facilement un emploi
cette affaire d'équité et de justice
dans une société de liberté et de
responsabilité
tout cela n'a de sens mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que si nous
renforçons l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi
nous y dédieront une part des économies
dégagées et nous associerons les
partenaires sociaux et les acteurs de
terrain pour trouver des solutions
concrètes efficaces
c'est l'objet même de la mobilisation
territoriales que le gouvernement
conduit avec les élus locaux et les
partenaires sociaux
retisser le lien social implique aussi
de renforcer la solidarité entre les
générations
nous le savons tous nous l'expérimentons
dans nos vies personnelles
l'indépendance est l'un des aspects pas
le plus réjouissant de cette révolution
de la longévité qui bouleverse
silencieusement de société nous avons
trop tarder
nous y confronter parce que les budgets
en jeu sans y dantesque peut-être aussi
par une forme de déni c'est évidemment
notre regard qui doit changer
celui que nous portons sur la place des
personnes âgées dans notre société nous
devons accompagner leur volonté de
vieillir à domicile entendre les
familles qui supporte une charge
financière importante et qui sont prises
en tenaille entre leurs obligations
d'enfants et celle de plus par an voire
deux grands parents entendre les
personnels dont le métier doit être
revalorisé et imaginer des solutions qui
s'applique dans un monde qui vieillit
certes dans une france qui vit mais dans
une france qui se transforme et où les
solidarités familiales sont très
différentes dans la façon dont elles se
mettent en oeuvre aujourd'hui de ce
qu'elle était il ya 50 ou il ya 60 ans
nous devons donc trouver les instruments
de financement de revalorisation
d'investissement et d'accompagnement
nécessaires à adapter notre pays à cet
enjeu la ministre des solidarités de la
santé présentera à la fin de l'année un
projet de loi qui définira la stratégie
et la programmation des moyens
nécessaires pour prendre en charge la
dépendance dès le prochain projet de loi
de finances pardon dès le prochain
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale nous enclencheront une
première étape avec des mesures
favorisant le maintien à domicile et des
investissements dans les ehpad cela fait
dix ans que l'on parle et que parfois
l'on promet cette grande réforme de
dignité et de fraternité nous voulons la
conduire et elle constituera à n'en pas
douter un grand marqueur social de ce
quinquennat
l'autre grand défi de notre génération
c'est la mise en place d'un système
universel de retraite
le haut commissaire jean paul delevoye
après avoir engagé des consultations
très intense dès le mois de janvier 2018
présentera au mois de juillet ces
recommandations
il garantira les mêmes droits et les
mêmes règles pour tous quels que soient
les statuts un système illisible et
rarement à système juste
ce système sera plus redistributif car
il réduira l'écart entre les tensions
les plus modestes et celle des plus
aisés il réduira l'écart entre celle des
hommes et celle des femmes et nous
serons particulièrement vigilants à ceux
qui ont exercé des métiers pénibles et
qui se retrouve parfois en situation
d'invalidité
disons la vérité aux français il faudra
travailler plus longtemps c'est une des
clés de la réussite du pays et les
français sont lucides les français sont
lucides déjà l'âge légal l'âge moyen de
départ à la retraite est supérieur à
l'âge légal parce que nos compatriotes
savent que grâce à leur travail ils
peuvent bénéficier d'une meilleure
pension et ils ont raison
nous maintiendrons donc la possibilité
d'un départ à 62 ans
mais nous définirons comme je l ai
indiqué hier un âge d'équilibré des
incitations à travailler plus longtemps
soyons enfin lucide sur l'état financier
de nos rêves de nos régimes de retraite
contrairement à ce que l'on a pu croire
il y a quelques années le système de
retraite n'est pas encore à l'équilibré
les dernières projections du conseil
d'orientation des retraites font
apparaître un besoin de financement de 9
milliards en 2020 de 2,16 milliards en
au delà le système ne reviendrait pas à
l' équilibre avant les années 2040 2050
sous des hypothèses de croissance
favorables et à cette échéance les
hypothèses de croissance sont ce
qu'elles sont cela montre la nécessité
c'est à dire des hypothèses
cela montre la nécessité d'être
attentifs dans la construction du
système universel et de le faire sur des
bases financières solides retisser le
lien social c'est assurer l'ordre et la
sécurité dans le pays soutenir nos
forces de sécurité à l'intérieur et nos
soldats à l'extérieur retisser le lien
social c'est regarder en face les
phénomènes qui inquiète les français
pour leur montrer que nous pouvons
garder le contrôle
c'est renforcer la laïcité c'est
maîtriser les flux migratoires
j'ai annoncé que le parlement débat très
en septembre retisser le lien social
s'est renforcé un modèle qui n'est plus
toujours adaptée aux évolutions de notre
société
je pense aux nouvelles solidarités pour
les familles monoparentales aux aidants
je pense au projet de revenu universel
d'activité qui simplifiera le système d
et mettra un terme au scandale du non
recours je ne reviendrai pas sur les
mesures par lesquelles nous misons sur
l'égalité des chances dès le plus jeune
âge dès que commencent les
apprentissages fondamentaux miser sur
l'égalité des chances notamment dans les
quartiers c'est ce que nous faisons en
augmentant le nombre de places en crèche
en limitant le nombre d'élèves par
classe en créant des sites et éducatives
d'excellence et des campus connecter la
création d'une loi de programmation pour
la recherche qui prendra effet à partir
de 2021 et qui sera discutée en 2020
répond à cette même conviction on
n'investira jamais assez sur
l'intelligence et sur la liberté
c'est pourquoi l'une des priorités de
l'acte 2 du quinquennat sera de lutter
contre toutes les formes d'assignation à
résidence
notamment territoriale et c'est le point
que je développerai aujourd'hui devant
vous car je n'ai pas abordé hier devant
l'assemblée nationale
je voulais en sorte en quelque sorte
réservé puisque vous êtes l'émanation
des territoires des villages et des
villes de france et 96 heures pendant
lesquelles le président de la république
a échangé avec des maires de france de
grand bourg de grands bourgtheroulde
dans leur code than encore marqueront
l'histoire de ce quinquennat
elles ont placé les maires dans la
lumière en mettant au jour ce que nous
savons leur dévouement et leur
sensibilité mais aussi leur
découragement nous ne pourrons pas
transformer le pays sans les mères sans
les élus locaux la démocratie n'est
qu'une coquille vide et que nous disent
les maires ils l'ont dit et répété il
paye le prix de baisses de dotations et
celui de la loi notre notamment qui a pu
conduire à la création
d'intercommunalité de taille xxl et à
des grandes régions qui sont parfois
encore contester et non pas encore ou
pas forcément contribué à rapprocher les
citoyens des lieux de décisions j'en
citerai un sol de grand-bourg tu roules
quand est-ce qu'on arrête la machine à
broyer la proximité
[Applaudissements]
g
j'ai peut-être mes chers collègues
oublier de citer la date à laquelle ont
été adoptés les dispositifs législatifs
que je viens de mentionner
je crois que chacun s'en souvient
parfaitement
cette exigence de proximité c'est une
rupture dans les politiques publiques
penet depuis longtemps et elle engage
autant les collectivités territoriales
que l'état s'agissant des collectivités
territoriales nous avons trois défis
d'abord conforter les maires au moment
où la crise de l'engagement est aiguë
pour la première fois pour la première
fois de nombreuses listes aux prochaines
élections municipales seront peut-être
incomplète et parfois qui sait nous
manqueront de candidats cette crise de
l'engagement nous devons y répondre
plus qu'un statut les maires veulent
d'abord un cadre clair d'exercice de
leurs mandats et plus de libertés
locales pour mieux mener leurs projets
ce cadre il doit être dans la loire pour
ne pas dépendre des situations locales
il doit garantir une véritable formation
une protection juridique un
accompagnement professionnel et familial
le sénat a déjà formulé des propositions
nous les reprendrons très largement
il s'agit aussi de lutter contre ce
sentiment de dépossession des mères et
de refaire droit aux libertés locales
des marges de manoeuvre doivent être
recherchées sur les effets de seuil qui
pénalise bien souvent les communes de
petite taille sur le renforcement des
pouvoirs de police du maire sur la
surpression d'obligations ou de contrôle
qui sont parfois superflus il s'agit
enfin de retrouver un équilibre au sein
du bloc local entre les communes et
leurs intercommunalités
ces dernières sont indispensables pour
porter les projets collectifs
c'est bien souvent à l'échelle d'une
intercommunalité que se gère les
questions d'économie circulaire de
réseau le logement de mixité sociale
d'infrastructures et de mobilité
mais force est de constater que si le
maire est toujours à portée
d'engueulades pour reprendre
l'expression chère au président du sénat
il n'a plus toujours à portée de main
les leviers de décisions et actions
les récentes faire les récentes réformes
dont la loi notre ont parfois créer des
irritations qu'il convient aujourd'hui
de corriger autour du triptyque
compétences périmètre gouvernance j'ai
demandé à sébastien lecornu de
travailler avec le sénat avec l'ensemble
des présidents des groupes du sénat et
avec les associations d'élus pour
déposer avant la fin du mois de juillet
un projet de loi engagement et
proximité conformément à l'article 39 de
la constitution notre haute assemblée en
sera saisi en premier dès la rentrée le
deuxième défi c'est de préparer un
nouvel acte de décentralisation
le président de la république en
conclusion du grand débat nous a invités
à la fois à achever les transferts de
compétences déjà entamés en supprimant
les doublons et à examiner de nouveaux
transferts dans les domaines du logement
des transports de la transition
écologique
j'ai chargé jacqueline gourault de
préparer cette importante réforme
dans un premier temps d'ici juillet la
ministre recevra l'ensemble des
associations
d'abord séparément puis tout ensemble en
associant les parlementaires à partir de
la rentrée de septembre dans chaque
région
ce dialogue se poursuivra localement
chaque préfet de région sera le garant
dans le cadre des conférences
territoriales de l'action publique qui
réunissent tous les élus l'état fixera
un cadre mais dans chaque région nous
ouvriront la voie à la différenciation
pour définir avec chaque territoire une
réponse adaptée sur mesure dans le cadre
d'un droit clair mais adaptable
c'est la voie que nous avons choisie
avec la bretagne ou avec les deux
départements du bas-rhin et du haut-rhin
qui formeront bientôt la collectivité
européenne d'alsace c'est la voie que
nous avons choisie pour la compétence
rsa avec la guyane et mayotte ou encore
la réunion c'est aussi bien sur la voie
que nous avons choisie pour la corse
la révision constitutionnelle consacre
sa spécificité et je me rendrai début
juillet
certaines des évolutions qui émergeront
de ces consultations locales pourront
être mises en oeuvre à droit constant
c'est à dire sans attendre d'autres
nécessiteront d'adapter la loi
elles viendront nourrir un projet de loi
décentralisation et différenciation que
jacqueline gourault présentera à la fin
du premier semestre 2020 le cadre sera
donc définie avant les échéances
électorales de 2021 pour y arriver
et parce que la situation au fil des
réformes successives est devenu
compliqué il faut partir de principes
clairs se rappeler par le président de
la république
d'abord la proximité voire la
subsidiarité quel est le bon échelon le
plus en capacité de répondre à la mise
en oeuvre des politiques publiques ou de
conduire certains investissements
et ce bon et cela n'est pas toujours
partout le même
ensuite la responsabilité politique on
ne peut plus continuer à détacher les
compétences et une fille nés les
résultats des élections en votant pour
un maire le citoyen c'est très bien cela
engage son vote en votant par le
président de la république le citoyen
c'est très bien c'est pourquoi son vote
s'engage entre les deux reconnaissons
que c'est parfois encore un peu plus
flou enfin qui décident paye et qui paye
commande mais qui commanda sud c'est
toute la question des ressources des
collectivités
et c'est le troisième défi nous devons
être capable de préciser aux élus avant
le prochain mandat municipal
le cadre financier dans lequel ils
exerceront leurs fonctions depuis deux
ans la dgf est stable globalement et
nous avons augmenté la péréquation pour
les communes rurales et urbaines les
plus fragiles nous préserverons cet
acquis s'agissant de la fiscalité nous
inscrirons dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2020 les modalités de
suppression complète de la taxe
d'habitation et de sa compensation
depuis de 2017 grâce aux travaux menés
en particulier par alain richard
les enjeux et les options de cette
réforme sont connus ils ont été
largement débattues le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs fait connaître dès le mois de
juillet 2018 les principes qui lui
paraissent les plus appropriées aucune
commune ne perdra de ressources
chaque contribuable bénéficiera à plein
de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
aux termes de la réforme la fiscalité
locale devrait être plus clair pour le
contribuable
c'est sur ces bases que gérald darmanin
et jacqueline gourault reprendront dès
la semaine prochaine les concertations
avec les associations de collectivités
territoriales je souhaite que ces
concertations soit le plus approfondi
possible la proximité
c'est aussi la sphère de l'état
rapprocher la décision des territoires
et de nos concitoyens passe par une
action méthodique de déconcentration
tous azimuts la décision individuelle
prises au niveau national doit devenir
l'exception est l'exception la plus rare
nous avons engagé un travail et je le
dis mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un travail de fourmi
6pour décision après décision se poser
cette question qu'est ce qui empêche que
cette décision puisse être prise au
niveau local ce travail aboutit à ce que
d'ici la fin de l'année plus des 95% des
décisions individuelles seront
effectivement prises dans les
territoires
tout au long du second semestre 2010 9
nous allons publier les textes
réglementaires qui met en musique cette
ambition il nous faut ensuite inversé
les logiques à l'oeuvre depuis 15 ans là
où on a concentré les forces au niveau
régional je souhaite renforcer le niveau
départemental et quand tous les réseaux
de services publics se sont
progressivement rétracter je souhaite
reconstruire un vrai maillage cohérent
de présence des services publics
j'ai signé hier l'instruction qui engage
la réorganisation des services
territoriaux de l'état pour supprimer
les doublons clarifier les
responsabilités mettre en cohérence nos
priorités avec nos organisations et
comme je l'évoquais à l'instant pour
mettre les préfets de département en
capacité d'agir au plus près des
territoires construire avec les conseils
départementaux le service public de
l'insertion déployer le service national
universel accompagner les petites
collectivités dans leurs projets
d'ingénierie
nous aurons aussi pour cela de nouveaux
outils je pense à la banque des
territoires qui a déjà commencé à
déployer ses financements
je pense à la une c'est et qui va
progressivement jouer un rôle majeur
dans la cohésion des territoires
cette instruction fixe également le
cadre pour superviser la réorganisation
des implantations de service public
le président de la république l'a
annoncé dans sa conférence de presse du
25 avril plus de fermetures d'écoles ou
d'hôpital sans accord du maire le
corollaire de cela c'est la nécessité de
mettre fin à des stratégies de
réorganisation sur les territoires qui
sont mal coordonnée entre les ministères
par son antre du ministère entre eux et
entre les ministères et les opérateurs
dorénavant les préfets de région
animeront avec les préfets de
département les chefs de services
régionaux de l'état et l'ensemble des
patrons d'opérateurs une instance
spécifiquement dédiés à des
réorganisations pour construire une
vraie stratégie la partager avec
l'ensemble des élus locaux et acteurs
professionnels concernés la dernière
brique de cette stratégie de proximité
des services publics c'est bien entendu
france service l'idée est simple
construire un guichet unique avec des
agents polyvalents capables de répondre
aux besoins de nos concitoyens dans
leurs démarches administratives
la réalisation nous le savons est plus
complexe
depuis plusieurs années les maisons de
services au public ont tenté d'apporter
cette forme de réponse avec un succès
variable
quel que soit l'engagement de celles et
ceux qui font vivre ces structures nous
devons changer d'échelle et changer de
logique partir des besoins de nos
concitoyens partir des besoins des
territoires dépassé les frontières des
administrations oublier que nous sommes
l'état le département la cpn ou la caf
ça veut dire des choses simples des
horaires d'ouverture élargis des agents
polyvalents forme et capable d'offrir
immédiatement des réponses ou
d'accompagner vers la bonne porte
d'entrée dès le 1er janvier 2020
je souhaite que 300 maisons france
services soient pleinement opérationnels
et le président de la république comme
le gouvernement se sont engagés à ce que
d'ici la fin du quinquennat nous
puissions disposer au moins d'une de ses
maisons à haute à haut niveau de service
par canton
j'ai commencé mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs part évoqué l'urgence
climatique avant de m'attarder sur
l'urgence de proximité mais ces deux
urgences coïncide en grande partie comme
le prouve l'exemple des outre-mer depuis
deux ans on a bien vu que nos
compatriotes ultramarins sont aux
avant-postes des cyclones ou de
l'élévation des océans causée par le
dérèglement climatique
nous en sommes tellement conscient
depuis le début du quinquennat que cette
double préoccupation définit les cinq
objets pardon les cinq objectifs du
livre bleu outremer rendu public le 28
juin 2018
nous avons pris ces cinq objectifs dans
la feuille de route du gouvernement pour
les outre mer
zéro vulnérabilités zero exclusion zéro
déchet zéro carbone zéro power agricole
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
l'impératif de différenciation intégrer
les spécificités de chaque territoire
pour adapter nos politiques publiques
c'est le réflexe outre-mer que nous
avons musclées depuis le début du
quinquennat
je voudrais enfin mentionner la
situation spécifique de la nouvelle
calédonie dont certains ça lui sied
combien elle me tient à coeur
nous sommes engagés à respecter la
signature de l'état sur l'accord de
nouméa et je continuerai à privilégier
la voie de nouméa c'est à dire celle du
dialogue et des résultats rendus en
toute transparence
lorsque le cycle électoral récemment
engagée aura été conclu je retrouverai
avec plaisir les représentants des
partis politiques de nouvelle-calédonie
les représentants des forces politiques
pour évoquer avec eux la suite
dernier point que j'aborderai ce matin
la réforme des institutions
le président de la république a proposé
aux français de réviser la constitution
du 4 octobre 58 pour l'adapter aux
bouleversements de notre démocratie il
ya un an nous avions présenté un projet
de loi constitutionnelle et deux projets
de loi complémentaire organique et
ordinaire
les circonstances ont reporté leurs
examens mais ces derniers mois nous ont
confortés dans la détermination à
rénover notre démocratie représentative
s'engager dans la révision
constitutionnelle sans l'accord du sénat
n'est tout simplement pas possible et
n'aurait donc aucun sens c'est pourquoi
depuis un an nous avons discuté et
essayer de trouver un compromis
les textes que nous nous apprêtons à
déposer sur le bureau de l'assemblée
nationale reprennent le coeur des
engagements du président de la
république y compris
l'inscription de la lutte contre le
changement climatique à l'article 1er de
notre constitution
ils sont recentrés sur trois priorités
les territoires avec l'autorisation de
la différenciation l'assouplissement du
cadre relatif à la corse ainsi qu'aux
outre-mer la participation citoyenne
avec un nouveau titre dans la
constitution la transformation du saison
on conseille de la participation
citoyenne la possibilité de former des
conventions de citoyens tirés au sort
la facilitation du recours au référendum
d'initiative partagée et l'extension du
champ de l'article 11
la justice enfin avec l'indépendance du
parquet et la suppression de la cour de
justice de la république
en parallèle des gestes ont été faits
pour parvenir à un consensus
les dispositions relatives au
fonctionnement des assemblées ont été
retirés nous avons considéré qu'il
appartenait aux assemblées elles mêmes
de décider de leurs efforts les
dispositions relatives au cumul des
mandats dans le temps ont été assouplies
pour en exclure les maires de communes
de petite taille et prévoir une engrais
une entrée en vigueur progressive
le président de la république a accepté
de revoir sa proposition de baisse d'un
tiers du nombre de parlementaires pour
viser une réduction d'un quart qui
permet une juste représentation
territoriale et l'introduction d'une
dose significative de proportionnelle à
l'assemblée
concrètement aujourd'hui il me semble
que nous ne sommes pas éloigné d'un
accord sur le projet de loi
constitutionnelle mais pas sur le projet
de loi organique et en particulier mais
pas seulement sur la question du nombre
de parlementaires le sénat a été très
clair sur le fait qu' ignorer d'accord
sur rien s'il n'y avait pas d'accord sur
tout et c'est parfaitement respectable
comme est parfaitement respectable je
crois la position du gouvernement qui ne
souhaitent pas à mobiliser du temps
parlementaire si in fine et ils
s'exposaient aux désaccords du sein nous
ne renonçons donc pas nos ambitions qui
nous le pensons sont conformes à la
demande de nos concitoyens nous
attendrons le moment propice et la
manifestation de volonté du sénat nous
pouvons aussi voté seulement la
proportionnelle à l'assemblée sans
changer le nombre de députés chacun
jugera dans quelle mesure il tient à
résoudre les points d accord qui demeure
chacun jugera dans quelle mesure ils
considèrent que cette réforme
constitutionnelle peut être un
instrument de renouveau démocratique et
de réconciliation nationale nous sommes
prêts et nous sommes ouverts
les trois textes sont prêts cette
réforme institutionnelle nous ne
pourrons pas là réussir sans vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je le disais à l'assemblée l'époque
exige une forme de dépassement en vous
demandant d'approuver cette déclaration
de politique générale
je ne vous demande
un blanc seing pour la politique de mon
gouvernement ni évidemment quelconque
ralliement la majorité je vous demande
de dépasser les clivages et des
différences que je respecte et qu'il me
semble plus aujourd'hui les plus
importants je vous ai exposé une feuille
de route d'ambition écologique de
justice sociale de valorisation du
travail de renforcement des maires de
réforme de l'état beaucoup de ces thèmes
me semble largement consensuel sur ses
bancs je forme le voeu qu'il n'aurait eu
ce qu'ils nous réunissent et qui nous
permettent de nous dépasser et je sais
que sur chacun des textes en particulier
au delà de la déclaration générale le
travail accompli entre le gouvernement
et le sénat sera riche et sérieux pour
toutes ces raisons j'ai l'honneur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs en application
des dispositions de l'article 49 alinéa
4 de la constitution de vous demander
l'approbation de cette déclaration de
politique générale
et je vous remercie monsieur le premier
ministre
nous allons revenir mes chers collègues
aux interventions des orateurs des
groupes politiques dans le débat la
parole est d'abord au président hervé
marseille et il a diminué
[Applaudissements]